welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and we have
some massive updates on tall up and done
death there have been several watch
parties since the lock downs were
initiated and Tiger Woods et recently
did one for thor ragnarok which included
an appearance by Tessa Thompson and Mark
Ruffalo the director dropped a ton of
information on thaw love and thunder and
it definitely deserves a breakdown
throughout this video we're going to be
going through all of the highlights of
the stream including news on the Hulk
Silver Surfer Loki and more there will
be some spoilers here so if you want to
go into the movie as blind as possible
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel to never miss an update and
please drop a thumbs up if you hyped for
the film without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of Thor love and thunder okay
so you may have seen recently that Thor
live and thunder was pushed back to
February 18th 2022 due to the major
delays that are going on in Hollywood
right now whilst this is a bad thing for
fans it actually gives the creative team
a lot of time to iron out all of the
kinks in the script but several new
aspects in place and also give us the
best movie possible due to Thor Ragnarok
and the way that things were left at the
end of Avengers endgame a lot of people
are highly anticipating the film's
release and there's a ton of things to
look forward to at San Diego Comic Con
last year we did get our first major
update about the film and during the
Marvel panel we learned that Natalie
Portman would be returning as Jane
Foster similar to the comic books she
will become the next version of Thor and
at the panel we even got to see a lift
Moliere since then we discovered that
the guardians of the galaxy will
definitely be appearing in the film and
that Valkyrie will be an openly gay
character
Christian Bale will also be playing the
movie's main villain and this was big
news a couple of weeks ago when it was
announced now the live stream was
absolutely packed with information but
IKEA also threw in some joke leaks so
she's a fake script page that showed the
return of Toni stock in it there was a
massive strike and when the dust settled
Toni was there and he said was a Thor
said Tony and Tony said
perfectly knowable perfectly Tony though
then exclaimed you're back Tony said
back in the sack and they hugged door
said but how I saw you die and Tony says
science he also has teased that Thanos
was back and that the Avengers needed to
reassemble and someone on Marvel Studios
spoilers asked if this was a real script
or not anyway that was the big troll of
the stream but the things that got
confirmed are just as furnaces fake page
now firstly we do know that thaws time
on the Benatar with the Guardians will
be temporary the god of thunder sailed
off into the stars with them at the end
of endgame and know they will be in the
film they won't be around for long as
for the rumors about beta ray bill being
in the film were TT did quash these a
bit though he did leave things open
potentially allowing for the character
to fit in somewhere
beta ray was teased in Thor Ragnarok as
a gladiator
but when discussing the matter with TT
stated that the situation was up in the
air at the moment and that he didn't
know if he was allowed to use him just
yet
perhaps Kevin Feige is saving him for
down the line as we do know that marble
like to plan far ahead in advance though
at the moment it doesn't seem like he's
going to be in the film it could just be
a bait and switch but yeah for the time
being it doesn't seem like anything is
locked down with tt then revealed some
concept art that show that the citizens
of new as God will be blending in with
the humans on earth and that their
village will become more human like meek
was also shown in a formal woman suit
away wait is Mick a girl well that's the
last time I ever assume anyone's gender
again so yeah they'll be done in
business attire probably ordering more
pizzas and playing for tonight like
they're in isolation meek was also shown
in a Warrior's getter so we will
probably be seeing the character
fighting out in the film at some point
in addition to this we will also be
diving into Korg's origin story and
exploring where he came from called is
probably the greatest character that the
MCU has ever produced and love and
thunder will discuss his origins
homeworld and what he used to get up to
looking like a rock with teetee stated
during the stream we do touch on quarks
culture where he's from if you look in
the comics about
it's an interesting thing about where
they come from so yeah there's a lot of
things to look forward to if you love
Korg as much as we here at the channel
do now as for broth or what TD did tease
that Thor will be back in shape for the
film and he said though they hadn't
figured out yet exactly how they would
trim him down he did feel like the broth
or aesthetic was now done another plot
thread that was left dangling at the end
of Avengers endgame was what happened to
Loki the character managed to disappear
with the tesseract and know we know for
definite that he will be returning for a
Disney Plus series many are wondering
whether he'll be back on the big screen
would he Lee stated that he simply
couldn't say if fans will get to see him
return which pretty much confirms to me
at the very least that we will be seeing
that god of mischief back on the big
screen soon it's not really a denial and
it wouldn't really be a Thor movie
without an appearance by him so it does
seem like he will be back
Mark Ruffalo also said that he may be
returning as the Hulk for the film and
know he was still on earth at the end of
Avengers endgame it does make sense in
some ways for him to come back Hulk
knows Korg meek the Asgardians and
Valkyrie and they all remained on it -
it is possible that he will
venture-backed in you as God and fly out
into the cosmos with Valkyrie and Co
which will likely be what happens in the
film in order for him to have a larger
role I'd love to see more development on
the new smart Hulk persona
and as the character is not able to
feature in solar movies diving deep into
his development makes sense in films
like this Hulk is actually my favorite
Marvel character so I'm always up for
seeing him on the silver screen
speaking of silver this is about to be
the most tenuous link ever
but what et did shut down rumors that
the Silver Surfer would be featuring the
film Bale at one point was rumored to be
playing him but what et debunked these
reports and revealed that he would not
be making an appearance in the film
however there would be some new
characters debuting in the movie and we
do know now that the star sharks will be
making an appearance these villains will
definitely make for some great foes for
the group to go off against and I think
it's an inspired choice to bring them
across they recently featured in Jason
Aaron's Doran and they provided some
brilliant action scenes so fans of the
comic book Ron
have a lot to look forward to now before
we get into the rest of the video which
talks about a deleted scene in Ragnarok
I just want to let you know we're giving
away a free copy of the Star Wars
Skywalker saga box set to one random
subscriber all you have to do to being
with the chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts and the updates in the
comments section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of April
and the set will be shipped out from the
end to ever get surprise so best of luck
to everyone who takes part okay so
that's all of the love and thunder
updates but what TT did also discuss the
Ragnarok namely one of the deleted
scenes which originally had Odin's death
taking place in an alleyway Odin was a
homeless man Thor and Loki stumbled
across before he passed away when
discussing it with TT said here's the
thing alleyways aren't cool fields are
cool ask anyone we originally shot some
of that stuff on the set of our stuff in
New York what we wanted to do was have
them go to earth and they see Doctor
Strange and stuff but it felt too
convenient that he was suddenly just
down the road in an alley and also
everything up to then everything was so
fast paced and all over the place we
wanted to go somewhere peaceful and
actually chill out with those characters
and be with Odin while he imports this
wisdom and stuff and not have to hear
stupid yellow cabs honking out the back
so that's why they changed it just in
case you were wondering would TD closed
out the stream by saying that the film
will be very over-the-top and that it's
like 10 year olds told us what should be
in a movie and we said yes to every
single thing it sounds like there's a
lot going on but if anyone can pull it
off I definitely think that it's were TT
as his films never really disappoint
overall this has gotten me a lot more
excited for the movie that sounds like
it's going to be a massive entry in the
Marvel Universe and a lot of people are
expecting the MCU to take a dip after
endgame but when things sound this good
it's difficult to see how now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
news and what you would have seen in the
film comment below and let me know and
if you enjoy this video then please give
it a thumbs up make sure you check out
our full breakdown of some of the big
updates we now know about the Batman
from an interview with Matt Reeves
earlier this week we go over all of the
ins and outs of the discussion so it's
definitely worth checking out if you're
interested in the movie if you want to
support the channel Brahmins letters
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below we massively
appreciate you and as a thank you you
get access to content early you want to
come chat to us after the show either
follow us at definition whitey or click
the discord link in the description
below those are the best ways to keep up
to date with heavy spoilers so hopefully
we see over there very soon this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]